>> THERE'S SOMETHING HAPPENING
IN TEXAS.
>> HOW Y'ALL FEELING TODAY?
>> FEELING?
>> THE MOST CLOSELY WATCHED RACE
IN AMERICA.
>> I SAID, HOW Y'ALL FEELING
TODAY?
>> DALLAS.
>> IT IS ELECTRIC.
>> Y'ALL LIKE?
TED CRUZ?
>> WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND OUT.
>> TED CRUZ.
♪
>> HI.
I'M TED CRUZ.
HE DIDN'T TELL ME IT WAS GOING
TO BE A POPULARITY CONTEST BUT
WE ARE GOING TO THROW THE
COOLEST RALLY IN TOWN.
WHAT DO YOU CALL A DEMOCRAT?
>> MAYBE TED CRUZ CAN'T SOUND
COOL, BUT I BET WE CAN MAKE HIM
LOOK COOL.
>> WHO WANTS TO SEE TED CRUZ
DUNK A BASKETBALL?
>> NEED TO HIT THE EMERGENCY
PARTY BUTTON.
>> OKAY.
>> TED'S NOSE IS BLEEDING.
JUST WRAP THIS UP.
>> GIVE IT UP ONE MORE TIME FOR
TED CRUZ.
>> YOUR FUTURE SENATOR.
>> TED CRUZ.